luz verde para el juicio político contra
el presidente sebastián piñera tras más
de 15 horas de reunión la cámara de
diputados de chile aprobó pasar al
senado la propuesta de moción con 78
votos a favor resultado de la votación
67 en contra de su atención
[Aplausos]
sebastián piñera fue uno de los tres
mandatarios latinoamericanos
implicados en los pandora papers debido
a la venta de una empresa minera en las
islas vírgenes británicas y aunque el
mandatario ha defendido que el proceso
fue legal el escándalo le ha llevado a
su segundo juicio político un día en que
termina aún que sea en esta cámara la
impunidad con la que ha gobernado piñera
la impunidad como autor de las graves
violación a los derechos humanos del
estado social y en la impunidad en que
está anteponiendo sus intereses
personales siempre a los intereses de la
nación se espera que el senado vote el
proceso de acusación entre el viernes y
el lunes aunque es improbable que la
emoción prospere ya que necesita ser
respaldada por más de dos tercios de la
cámara alta- lo que se traduce en 29
votos a favor y por el momento la
oposición solo cuenta con 24 su primera
acusación constitucional fue por
violación de derechos humanos durante el
estallido social de 2019 un duro golpe
para la imagen de la la conservadora
chilena de cara a las elecciones del
próximo 21 de noviembre